I know these problems are difficult, and
they take a lot of practice. Remember you
can always go back and review the lessons
if you need some help. The answer to this
problem is negative 28. Let's see how we
got that. The first thing I notice when
I'm looking at this problem is that
there's this inner parenthesis inside the
absolute value. So we have to perform the
operations inside the parenthesis. Before
we do anything else. When I'm looking at
the operations inside these parentheses I
notice that there's an exponent, and we
need to do exponents before multiplication
and before subtraction. So let's do 5
squared. Remember when you're doing
problems like this you should always copy
The operations that you didn't perform,
and only perform one or two operations at
each step, so I'm going to copy everything
down. The only think I'm going to do right
here is evaluate this 5 squared, and I
know that 5 squared is 25. The next think
I can do is evaluate multiplication and
division. There's only one multiplication
inside the parentheses, so let's evaluate
that and copy everything else down. 4
times 6 is 24 minus 25, and I have to cube
that, and I still have my absolute value.
Since there's one more operation inside
these inner parentheses, I have to do this
operation before I can do anything else. I
remember to copy everything else down. 24
minus 25 gives me negative 1, and I have
to raise negative 1 to the third power.
Now I can perform the operations inside
the absolute value and I can evaluate my
exponents first. So I have the negative
absolute value of 3 cubed is 3 times 3
times 3, which is 27. And then we have
negative 1 cubed which is negative 1,
times negative 1, times negative 1, which
is negative 1. Or you could also remember
that a negative number raised to an odd
power would give me a negative result. Now
we only have one operation left inside of
the absolute value, which is 27 minus
negative 1. So I have negative the
absolute value of 27 minus a negative 1,
which is 28. From he re, remember that
this negative out front actually means
negative 1 times, and the absolute value
of 28 is 28. So, I have negative 1 times
28, which gives me negative 28. These were
some good practice problems for both
absolute value and order of operations.
Why don't you try a couple more?